wir brauchen mehr waffen diese forderung
musste auch von der leyen mehrfach heute
hören und wir haben exklusiv auch mit
vladimir klitschko über den
hinterhältigen angriff auf den
flüchtlings bahnhof gesprochen er
fordert eindringlich konsequenzen auch
von deutscher seite
es ist gut dass
hochrangige politiker an reisen in die
ukraine
markierung es setzen den augen zusehen
wie die lage ist weil letztendlich wir
für daher nicht nur die ukraine wir
verteidigen auch unsere demokratische
werte weil wenn wir fallen dann fehlt
die westliche dauer und der erste welt
auch das waren tausende mehrere tausend
am bahnhof in kammerforst und genau da
dorthin am die russischen streitkräfte
gezielt es ist präzise
exekution
des gesunden bevölkerungs in der ukraine
präzise
russische armee hat genau gewusst das
sind die flüchtlinge
die gesammelt haben tausende davor die
um den weg waren und auf ihre züge
gewartet haben um in die sicherheit zu
kommen um dort
gezielt eine rakete
abzuschießen und die menschen töten das
ist wieder hören von
daten die vor kurzem in brand gestorben
butscher alpin
gemacht wurden im süden der ukraine
mein opa leidet nach wie vor
es ist die gefühle sind nicht zu
beschreiben diese sinnlose krieg muss
beendet werden
ich verstehe dass europa deutschland
konkret sehr abhängig von dem russischen
gas und öl ist ist aber machbar
in diesen zeiten wo wir zahlen mit dem
leben
vom öl und gas
russischen öl das sie zu treten die ums
ag in der ukraine wird nicht aufhören
werden wir nicht diese aggression
stoppen ich habe schon vor kurzem
genannt was dafür notwendig ist ich
wiederhole ist nur einmal im bagger von
öl und gas es ist ganz wichtig auch die
waffenlieferung für unsere ukrainischen
wir brauchen keine andere armeen auf dem
kirchenboden wie schaffen dass selbst
wir müssen uns verteidigen weil das
internationale recht ist gebrochen
worden in europa im zweiten weltkrieg in
europa in einem großen lernen der
europas die creme mit der russischen
version werden unsere zivilisten unserer
bevölkerung vernichtet wenn ein land das
andere land angegriffen hat und leute
haben ihre so wie wir in die ukraine um
sie zuhause verloren familienmitglieder
verloren familien komplett verloren sind
viele viele viele kinder umgebracht
worden
du hast keine andere wahl als sich wozu
für deine mobile ist enorm und diese
viele wird in on widerstand für diese
aggression die aus russland kam
diese viele wird es auch zum sieg führen
und unsere partner unsere weggefährten
auf die jungs ausführen lassen müssen
weil allein
wahrscheinlich werde das nicht schaffen
deswegen brauchen wir enorm diese
unterstützung von unseren weggefährten
und so ban seit 2004 zehn kämpfen wir
für diese freiheit stehen wir für diese
freiheit für demokratische werte die wir
teilen auch mit der europäische freiwild
wir müssen es schaffen wir haben keine
andere wahl und das werden wir schaffen
mit unterstützung gemeinsam werden wir
das recht bekommen um gewinnen diesen
sinnlosen klingt verteidigen unser recht
im freien europa zu leben es betrifft
nicht nur die ukraine es betrifft jeden
in europa weil diese vision wird weiter
rollen das haben die schon angekündigt
die
diese russische propaganda hat schon das
angekündigt dass die weiteren getreten
ist und der anfang vergessen sie nicht
über die zeiten der ddr
um die mauer vergessen sie nicht es kann
wieder zu bekommen das wollen wir nicht
deswegen müssen wir hier in der regel
ein stopp geben